despite the primetime opinion
programming on Fox News continuing to be
99.9% aggressively in favor of the
president there are more and more sort
of little cracks in the narrative at Fox
News and I have another one for you
today this is from Fox News legal
analyst Andrew Napolitano who's a former
Judge Napolitano suggested something
that we've all actually been saying for
a long time who are on the side of logic
reason and just observing what is out
there in the world which is that Donald
Trump may be unfit to serve as president
this is aside from his policy views this
is aside from the corruption and the
bribery bribery and everything else this
is not something you typically hear on
Fox News which makes it more important
it makes it more notable that that is
the venue in which it is being said so
we'll take a look at it this is from
Judge Andrew Napolitano is program
Liberty file on Fox nation I mean it's
it's all terrible right these can't be
the people we are looking to for
solutions in society but when they point
out the obvious it actually does say a
little something let's take a look at
what he had to say in nearly three years
in office president Donald Trump has
spent federal dollars not authorized by
Congress separated families and
incarcerated children at the
texas-mexico border in defiance of a
federal court order pulled 1000 American
troops out of Syria ignoring a
commitment to allies and facilitating
war against civilians there and sent
2,000 American troops to Saudi Arabia
without a congressional authorization or
declaration of war
he is also criminally obstructed a
Department of Justice investigation of
himself but escaped prosecution because
of the intercession of an attorney
general more loyal to him than to the
Constitution the Constitution at the
outset of his presidency Trump took the
presidential oath of office promising
that he would faithfully execute his
obligation to preserve protect and
defend the Constitution so here Judge
Andrew Napolitano is laying out some of
the actions of Donald Trump that are
problematic but then later in his
monologue he gets to the bigger picture
of Donald Trump's fitness for office and
he's pointing out you know initially he
points out all the ways in which Donald
Trump is
flouting the constitution he's ignoring
the rule of law but then Judge Andrew
Napolitano gets to this bigger picture
issue of trumps fitness President Trump
has become known for forceful and often
tasteless banter he publicly calls
people crude names uses foul language
and send sends dog whistles of lawless
behavior to many of his supporters all
of that is a question of free speech
personal taste and political risk but
threats to ignore parts of the
Constitution are not matters of speech
taste or risk they reveal character
traits that question the president's
fitness for office now he's not saying
that it's because of possible cognitive
decline or early dementia he's not
saying it's because of possible
amphetamine abuse which we've been
talking about but he is at least talking
about fitness which again you don't hear
this on Fox News in typical
circumstances now as a result of that
andrew napolitano may well end up like
Shep Smith meaning no longer working at
Fox News but at the same time let's not
underestimate the possibility of this as
a strategy these little sporadically
planted counter points to Donald Trump
including on their Fox Nation shows
which are I think Fox Nation is only
online or maybe buried somewhere on some
cable systems these little counter
points to trump could be a setup to
pivot away from Trump as more and more
supporters JumpShip if that happens
we're just an unprecedented territory we
have no idea ultimately what might
happen the circumstances today couldn't
be more different in Donald Trump's
fight for re-election than they were for
example when George W Bush was trying to
get reelected in 2004 back in 2004 there
was no impeachment inquiry against
George W Bush Fox News was totally
behind him the Republican establishment
was totally behind him in 2019 into 2020
Donald Trump is facing an impeachment
inquiry there are more Republicans than
we typically see in a Republican
administration who are disgusted with
what Trump is doing you are seeing
cracks in the armor of the right-wing
establishment media narrative so it is
unprecedented territory Andrew
Napolitano could simply be ignored
because Fox figures nobody's really
watching this guy on Fox Nation he could
be there specifically to do these things
to give fox cover to say we have
ideological balance or he could be there
to lay the groundwork in case Fox
decides they go a different direction
when it comes to their support of Trump
in 2020 although I don't find it
particularly likely